hey everyone did you know that algorithm
is one of several more recent projects
that aim to increase the range of
potential applications for
cryptocurrencies by speeding up
transaction processing and shortening
the time it takes for a transaction to
be considered final on a network
algorithm has grown consistently
throughout its existence this token
created to make blockchain more
environmentally friendly and advanced
through strategic collaborations saw a
10 spike in may 2022 in 24 hours
so considering this sudden surge in
popularity
i from simply learn have brought you a
new video on algorithm that will give
you all the knowledge needed to
understand the whole mechanism behind
algorithm so without any further ado
let's get started with the video but
before that do not forget to like this
video and subscribe to our youtube
channel to never miss an update from
simply learn
so
let's have a look at what we are going
to learn in this video
first we will learn what is algorithm
followed by what is algo
then we will look into its foundation
and protocol then we will understand
what is algorithms taking mechanism and
how does algorithm work and at the end
we will see how to buy algorithm
so before we understand the in-depth
mechanism of algorithm let's first
understand what algorithm
is the blockchain network and project
algorithm was established in 2017 by mit
computer scientist professor silvio
mckelly
in june 2019 algo the network's native
cryptocurrency and the mean it network
both became live
the blockchain facilitates smart
contracts and as was already mentioned
focuses on increased scalability with
support for customizable layer 1
blockchains the algorithm network is a
public decentralized pure proof of stake
blockchain
now these can be used to build
blockchains that are customized for
particular purposes
according to the initiative financial
services decentralized finance fintech
and institutions can all benefit freely
from its technology
well this reminds me do you know which
nation is the first nation to accept
digital currency
to figure out which nation is taking a
step toward future technology hang until
the end of this video till then you can
all comment down your answers below
now let's get back to the video
so now that we have come to its crypto
algo let's understand that also in
detail
the native currency of algorithm algo
has a total supply cap of 10 billion
coins which will be issued by 2030.
each newly forged block is accompanied
by a new algo that is sent to particular
algo holding wallets
so you must have at least one algo in a
non-custodial wallet to obtain these
algo incentives
approximately every 10 minutes this
reward which offers algo holders and apy
of between five and eight percent is
given out now due to this process you
can passively stake the algo coin making
it one of the easiest cryptocurrencies
to earn a passive income now that we
know what is algorithm let's have a look
at how its foundation was built and what
projects it deals with
the algorithm network is funded and
expanded by the algorithm foundation a
non-profit corporation that was
established in 2019.
additionally it contributes
significantly to blockchain governance
research and community
for instance the foundation has provided
developers with education through
university programs and has assisted
algorithm projects within its ecosystem
with accelerator programs
however the private corporation
algorithm incorporative is in charge of
technical development
additionally the algorithm foundation
holds a sizable amount of algo which it
utilizes to finance its operations
now this raises the question of what
protocol algorithm primarily follows so
let's have a peek at them
the algorithm network asserts to address
three main problems referred to as the
blockchain trilemma
security scalability and
decentralization
these are the three main issues the
algorithm protocol intends to address so
let's discuss them one by one
first is security
now the algorithm protocol is resistant
to malicious assaults which makes it
perfect for transactions keeping
valuable assets and developing secure
business applications
it keeps security at both the network
and consensus protocol levels and
safeguards user accounts individually
second is
decentralization
now algorithm lacks a single point of
control or centralized authority
participating nodes in the network
verify transactions and all nodes have
an equal voice in decision making
algorithm is an extremely decentralized
system as a result
so because the selection is both random
and private anybody on the network has a
chance to be a member of the committee
of users that approves each block
so there is a new set committee and
volunteers from all over the world
administered notes third is scalability
now the algorithm protocol is more
scalable than bitcoin or ethereum
because it can process several
transactions per second
now the consensus protocol developed by
algorithm eliminates the requirement for
the computational power that bitcoin or
ethereum uses to address cryptographic
issues well this brings us to the
staking mechanism of algorithm
algorithm employs a special proof of
stake variant known as pure proof of
stake
one algo token is all that is necessary
to participate in pure proof of state
and to help secure the network
on the contrary ethereum 2.0 has a 32
ether minimum stake requirement creating
a substantially higher entrance barrier
for consumers
on the other hand a low minimum staking
requirement can compromise network
security since users
may not act ethically if they have
little money at stake in the network
so now that we know that ethereum and
algorithm are closely working with proof
of stake there is a huge rivalry
competition between them
so let's see how they both actually
differ from each other
now blockchain technologies like
algorithm and ethereum can be seen as
rivals both platforms employ smart
contracts and provide the infrastructure
necessary for creating more
blockchain-based projects
so algorithm and ethereum differ from
one another primarily in the
blockchain's consensus mechanism
ethereum employs the proof of work
algorithm which needs a lot of energy
and processing power to mine new
currencies and complete transactions
ethereum is increasingly switching to
the proof of stake algorithm
the most popular kind that needs
blockchain network users to choose the
master validators
on the other hand algorithm is already
using pureprofile stake
now on average a new block of
transactions can be processed on the
ethereum platform every 12 to 14 seconds
whereas algorithm network transactions
are completed more quickly in less than
four seconds also
so now that we have covered all the
basics of algorithm let's dive deeper
and have a look at how it actually works
with proof of stake
now algorin has provided a two layer
smart contract design since 2020 that
differs significantly from past methods
and this is how it goes
now layer one is on chain for smart
contracts that carry out basic usually
transactions directly on the blockchain
now algorithm layer one deals with
atomic transfers or when several parties
consent to swap cash
whereas layer 2 is off chain and is for
specific two required smart contracts
this covers two large two complex or two
computationally demanding smart
contracts
the gist is that less complex smart
contracts which will take longer to
process operate outside the blockchain
and run on a different platform
now algorithm can operate more
efficiently than single layer blockchain
thanks to this architecture
algorithm uses a pure proof-of-stake
mechanism to validate transactions now
anyone can stake their tokens and take
part in the validation process
if they have at least one algo in their
possession the algorithm protocol
chooses participants to validate blocks
of transaction the possibility of
selection for each online user depends
on the number of algo tokens
users receive participation benefits for
confirming their transactions
so here are the three steps that
algorithm undergoes while working with
first is proposal stage
now users become participation nodes
once they have staked and generated
their participation key
algorithm relay nodes serve as the
channel for communication between these
nodes
now the block proposal phase then uses a
verifiable random function to choose
several block proposals while taking
into account the percentage of each
validator's state
the identity of the chosen block
proposal is hidden until the new block
is offered because harmful actors cannot
target the selected validator
network security also increases however
proposals can exhibit their vrf output
with the proposed block to demonstrate
their legitimacy
then comes the second stage this soft
board stage
participation notes are chosen randomly
to join the software committee after a
block has been submitted so that only
one candidate can add to the blockchain
this stage streams ideas
voting power on the soft committee is
proportionate to each note stake and
votes are utilized to choose the
proposed block with the lowest vrf hash
now because the lowest vrf hash is an
unpredictable value it will be hard to
attack the blog's proposal in advance
and then comes the last stage certified
vote stage
the integrity of the transaction in the
blog from the software stage will be
examined by a new committee established
to look for double spending now the
block is added if the committee accepts
the work if not a new block is chosen
the current block is rejected and the
blockchain goes into recovery mode
it is an aspect of pure proof of stake
consensus mechanism since the leader who
suggests a faulty block is not subject
to a slashing penalty algorithm folks
are relatively uncommon because only one
blog proposal may be certified at a
given time
all transactions are then deemed as
final after the block has been added
so now that we have covered all the
technical concepts and functionalities
of algorithm let me tell you where you
can actually buy algorithm
basically you have a wide range of
choices available when it comes to
purchasing cryptocurrencies thankfully
coinbase binance etoro kraken and
crypto.com works wherever algorithm is
available so you may purchase algorithm
it is speedy simple and secure
well this brings us to the end of this
video but before ending this video let's
have a look at the question i asked you
before in this video
well the first nation you to accept
digital currency is the marshall islands
the republic of the marshall islands is
a country that embraces emerging
technologies to create an open financial
system that uses blockchain technology
the sov a digital currency will coexist
with the us dollar in circulation and
support the marshall islands productive
participation in the world economy
well
i hope you enjoyed this video and
learned something new from it please
don't forget to give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to our youtube channel for
more interesting videos like this and if
you have any questions regarding this
video our team will reach out to you as
soon as possible thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here